Hello,
and welcome to tutorial two
part three of the complete gate to InfluxDB
two.
Today,
we're gonna take a look at what happens
after you first install or run InfluxDB.
We're going to run through the setup and
do a high level exploration
of the user interface and the different components
just to give you enough that you can
start to experiment and play with InfluxDB
on your own.
So let's get started.
Now I have just run InfluxD
like we did on the previous lesson.
Only I have not started on get started
yet, which we have to do now.
The thing that's important here is that InfluxDB
two does
not allow you to run or operate it
without configuring your first admin user.
Authentication
cannot be disabled.
You have to provide a username,
a secure password,
preferably not password one two three,
followed by an organization
name and a bucket name.
Let's talk about that.
InfluxDB
two point is multi tenant by default and
that your data,
dashboards,
your metrics
can all be
separated by organisations.
For today, I will create an organisation called
Rawkode.
Then we have buckets.
So we have to create our first bucket
as part of our organisation.
And buckets can be thought of like databases
in your more traditional database system.
Buckets and a time series database, specifically InfluxDB,
have retention policies.
So you use buckets as a way to
determine when data within that bucket should automatically
be expired.
For today, we will call this
tutorial.
That is us set up.
We could now log out and log back
in if we really wanted.
So InfluxDB
has a few different options that allow you
to get started.
You can go through some local metric collections.
You can start to specify and configure Telegraph,
or you could just say, I will do
this later, which is what we're going to
choose now.
So this is the user interface and this
is the getting started page.
We can use the load your data, build
a dashboard, or set up alerting buttons to
get,
well,
to get started on each of those tasks.
What we're gonna do first is just take
a look at the data tab.
So InfluxDB
has really great support across all of these
different client libraries and Telegraph plugins to start
getting metrics into your system. So it doesn't
matter what your stack is in your organization.
There is a pretty good chance that you
can get data into your InfluxDB two instance
pretty quickly.
We can click on buckets and we see
our bucket here, our tutorial one was created
with a retention policy of forever.
This means that any data that we write
to the tutorial bucket will never be expired.
Let's just create one more bucket
and we'll call this
five ms
and the
shortest retention policy is one hour, so we'll
call it one hour and
we will click create.
You can see now we have our one
hour bucket with our retention policy of one
hour.
Now, what happens here is InfluxDB runs compactions
at a regular interval and we'll look for
shards within each of these buckets that are
older than the time that we allow through
retention policy and also be automatically deleted for
us.
In future episodes of this course, we'll be
looking at how to downsample
and change the resolution of our data to
allow us to move it between buckets
that we can have high frequency, high resolution
data that lives for a short amount of
time and then aggregate it into other buckets
which live for a longer amount of time.
We talked about this briefly
in the very first part of this course,
an introduction to time series.
So stay tuned for that video.
The Telegraph UI allows us to very quickly
create a Telegraph configuration.
We can click on the components that we
have in our system and it will actually,
if we click continue,
allow us to configure
where
our Docker socket is.
For Kubernetes,
we can specify the URL.
Not the right port, but it's okay.
For NGINX,
and this does require your NGINX to have
the
stats plugin enabled.
We configure Redis. Now I'm not going to
do all of these because we don't need
them all. What I'm going to do is
disable
these.
We'll have our system. We'll select the one
hour bucket
and click continue. And we could give this
a name. We'll just call this system
monitoring.
This now gives us an InfluxDB
token
that we can export to our environment.
And a really cool feature of Telegraph that
we haven't covered yet,
and we will be in the next video
in a bit more detail, is the remote
configuration
where you can specify the URL to pull
your Telegraph config.
We can click finish here. Now the alternative
approach if you don't want to use the
remote configuration is to click on this one
more time,
and you can download it or copy and
paste it. And you'll see this is the
TOML required for each of the plugins that
we use.
Now you will still have to export your
Influx token to your environment for this configuration
to work.
Next, we have scrapers.
So InfluxDB
has built in support for fetching metrics from
remote endpoints. This works really well for Prometheus
endpoints that you have available where you want
to be able to scrape them on a
regular cadence,
but we're not going to be using that
today.
Lastly, on the data tab, we have the
ability to manage our tokens. This is my
initial admin token that was created when I
created the user,
and this is my generated token for the
Influx config that we generated through the UI.
Next, we have the Explore tab.
From here, we can begin to explore the
metrics that we have in our system.
Now, we don't have any metrics because we're
not collecting anything yet,
but we will be covering using the Explore
API and Avedio validation.
Next, have boards, which allows us to visualise
our data.
Now, because we generated our first Telegraph configuration
through the UI, this dashboard was added automatically.
Now if I were to begin running Telegraph,
we would see metrics and visualizations begin to
come in here.
The next tab we have is tasks.
We will be spending a significant
amount of effort playing with tasks over the
next week or two
because it's key to the way that we
work with downsampling and alerting our InfluxDB system.
Tasks allow us to write flux scripts that
can fetch and manipulate the data within our
database and use them to drive decisions and
automations in our infrastructure.
The next workshop will be this week, and
it will be focusing on writing your first
flux. Make sure to catch that.
Next, have the alerts tab. The alerts tab
allows us to then use our metrics to
be able to trigger notifications to Slack,
email, HTTP endpoints, and more,
so that we can understand and
trigger pagers,
send Slack messages, just get someone's attention when
we have an anomaly within our system.
And lastly,
we have our settings tab.
InfluxDB allows us to define variables that can
be used in our Flux scripts.
You can see here that the variable can
be of type query, map, or CSV.
So there's multiple ways to provide static values
or dynamic values from a query
to your Flux tasks and queries.
One of the coolest things about InfluxDB's
latest version, version two, is templates.
We will be spending also a significant amount
of time on using the GetOps pattern to
apply our telegraph configurations,
our dashboards and our tasks
using InfluxDB
two templates.
But we won't be looking at this today,
but we will have a really cool video
on that coming soon.
And lastly, we have the ability to manage
our labels.
Labels can be applied to any dashboard and
task, notebook, etcetera.
Cool feature. It just helps us manage
and structure the resources that we have available
in our InfluxDB two system.
So that's again in CertiKate.
Stay tuned. There'll be more videos coming really
soon.
I'll speak to you later. Have a great
day.